what'd you think of that like uh social
media
tick-tock video this weekend with cam
newton and the kid talking trash like
did you see that
oh well yeah we we had that scheduled
for later but we can go
get to it now okay i didn't even know we
had a good one for later do we want to
do we want to play some of it before
let's go let's play it let's play it
start now we'll do it live
we'll do it live
you're a free agent
yeah you know if you want some attention
i'm gonna give you some attention the
right way bro
the right way when do y'all play
tomorrow
what was your record today dude
what did you do i
i wasn't able to see because y'all was
cool camera's on me all right
what did he do man does he play he got
speed
he got speed
huh
oh
okay please don't be one-dimensional
it's like like you said something to me
didn't i well i'm really trying to talk
to you i'm not trying to like crack no
jokes i'm just really trying to ask a
simple question
it's your fault why everybody's looking
but i'm really just trying to ask this
question
but you never said what you did you said
you're going to see me
you're my grandmother right
coach because it's not disrespectful i
get that
right
uh
if all if all those kids look small no
cam newton's a giant let's not forget
that let's not forget that that
those people are normal sized it's cam
newton who is the guy down the beanstalk
who
happened to pass by the kid and look my
thought on all that
i said this last night on pftpm kid
showing off for his friends
that's all it is there's no deeper
message it's not some
some more ominous statement about where
we are as a society it is kids showing
off for his friends that has happened in
every generation
known to man you get around your buddies
and you want to impress them
and it's not like cam newton's going to
come over and beat him up no
right the adult's not going to beat up
the kid especially not with
a bunch of cameras around so that that's
all i saw that as and cam newton trying
to smooth it over and get the kid to
understand why he was being kind of
stupid for being disrespectful
but that that's all i saw in that i know
people are trying to make some broader
commentary about where we are as a world
but
it's just stupid kid trying to show off
for his friends well
i i don't know i'm a little listen i got
of course a 14 year old and a 10 year
old and i see this crap a lot
like first off let me just say this let
me or let me ask you this
if that was your son talking to cam
newton like that how would you would you
like that would you like would you no
no absolutely not right absolutely not
right that i would have major issues if
my son was that guy talking talking to
cam newton like that
i do but again but again i look i i said
plenty of things to people when i was a
kid and my friend
said plenty of things that my parents
and their parents would have been
mortified about if they had been around
kids act that way that's how they are
especially once the testosterone starts
flowing and they start
experimenting with how the world works
so
that to me isn't some litmus test that
makes this generation different i
have a really hard time thinking that
you were mouthing off like that to any
grown-up
as you were growing up at to that extent
i have i would have
i thought i could get away with it if i
thought i could get away with it i did
but but what what but it
i do think it speaks a little bit to a
bigger problem a little because
just the social media tick tock whatever
it is has just emboldened people
this generation is just fearless with
stuff like that they really are there's
some aspects that i love
hey they're not afraid to show their
emotions and dance and do
all those things that's really cool but
to me that that does cross the line that
crossed the line
cam newton is a legend
and he is taking time out of his life
to have a camp and you're at that camp
because of him and he is doing something
for the community
and you're gonna talk crap like that to
him that to me was crossing the line a
little bit i will say that and cam
newton did a really good job of kind of
defusing the situation
but there he was he's still trying to
talk to the kid and the kid's still
trying to put on a show for social media
because he knows the cameras are on
and all that and i do think it speaks to
a little bit of a bigger problem there
i'll disagree with you too
to a degree i agree with you you're
right their kids hey they're gonna talk
trash and show off
but i think that went above and beyond
just a hair and i think it just shows
you you know cam newton's ability to
communicate and handle people in tough
situations because that well that was
not easy and i i
i would be pissed at my kid if he came
home when i saw that video
two points one i i think that the
the desire to go viral that is
permitted by social media adds to the
desire
to show off right for your buddies not
only am i going to impress my friends
i'm going to impress my followers and
i'm going to get a lot more followers
if this thing lands on tick tock and
everybody's talking about it several
days after the fact
like we are now we have swallowed the
hook by merely talking about it
i'll also say this on the back half of
that
video when cam newton's trying to engage
the kid i
i couldn't quite hear it and
i but but i almost feel like cam was
trying to call the kid
out by suggesting what did you do today
you didn't do much today like in a
roundabout way of turning it around on i
mean it didn't work
he was never able to draw out enough
from the kid to really stick it to him
the way he wanted to and it was playful
it wasn't malicious he was trying to do
it playfully but it never
landed whatever it was that he was
trying to do on the back half of that
clip
never really struck the tone and the
chord that he was looking for
but i think he was trying to give it
back to the kid a little bit in a good
natured way
oh yeah exactly hey what'd you do today
let's talk about you
you know i mean let's not talk about me
i'm a free agent a la
nfl mvp and been to a super bowl and an
nfl legend
so he's trying to you know defuse the
kid that way but yeah
that that um i don't know it bothered me
a little bit it really did and i thought
cam newton did a pretty good job of
handling the situation either way
uh but it it is to me does speak a
little bit
to where we are because i just i see it
when my little girl's friends
my little boy's friends you know they're
not afraid to mouth off maybe as much as
my generation or the generation before
uh used to be i don't know apparently
you had a big mouth all the time wait
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute i'm not the one whose parents
took me on to the
regis philbin show where filming is the
case may be
and my parents had to worry about me
dropping the f-bomb while we just filmed
when i was four yes and and i'm not the
one who said to my dad while danny
devito was standing over there why is he
so little
well i was born maybe okay i was four
and it wasn't like i was trying to
disrespect anybody intentionally
talk crap i didn't know better at that
point if i was that
as i grew up i think anybody could tell
you i was a pretty respectful young man
especially of my elders and i still try
to be
that way so i just couldn't i couldn't
let that go
you're i'm 15 years older than you
you're not very respectful of me
now um i can't help but wonder though
right let's try to take this next level
from an analytical
perspective at some point during the
regular season cam newton was talking
about his performance his concern in
being
benched potentially and also he talked
about the locker room guys
talk right if they don't believe in the
quarterback they're going to talk
i think this is a broader
snapshot of that reality now where this
video
grew legs and people are talking about
it
and cam's got to be wondering is this
how kids view me am i viewed currently
as a failure am i at a
kind of a weird crossroads where
somebody's emboldened to call me out
because i'm not
the superman of five years ago i just
can't help but wonder that's
whether that's going to make him more
determined and more focused and more
relentless
in trying to get back toward the top of
the mountain with whatever his next team
is or whether he stays in new england i
i
i don't doubt that i mean he's he's
gonna grind and work
i've never heard anything different you
know i know a few people that he works
out with
in florida and does things like that you
know work ethic is not an issue for cam
newton he will attack
it that way uh certainly but
hey this is this is the generation that
we live in a little here too to like to
your point about how he's viewed
you know yeah there is some of that
right now it's like oh if you haven't
won
rings and you're not the best player
then i could talk trash to you even
though i'm not doing anything but
you know taking the trash out at home i
could talk trash to you even though
you're an awesome
professional athlete but you didn't win
championships so i can
i can bring you down that way you know
that that speaks to the broader problem
there all the way but yes
i think there's a little bit of that
younger generation
who might not have seen cam in his prime
and they've heard about it but
they haven't seen much of them the last
few years so they're not really aware of
what he was and they just look at
what this last year was and it wasn't
all that impressive
at the risk of prompting half of the
audience or let's say 30 percent to turn
the the show off at this point isn't
this what you get
when the leader of the country behaves
that way constantly talking trash
constantly calling out enemies
constantly
insulting people for five years isn't
isn't that part of the problem setting
aside social media
isn't that part of the problem it
normalizes that behavior
i don't want to go down this road but
but isn't it well
but we're there i know i'm trying to
figure out why this happens i've said
this
it's a product of having someone at the
top
of our national pyramid who is a bully
and a thug when it comes to dealing with
other people well that's why
i i've said i think it does speak to a
bigger problem
i do it's it's not just there you know i
grew up in north
jersey with you know a lot of
you know of course old school men
teaching me how to play football and do
those things and whatever else and
you know a lot of grown-ups that are
respecting all of that and of course
i've you know been in many
outings where hey you know they
they make fun of millennials oh
millennials oh
all they do is make excuses they don't
want to take they don't want to work
hard they don't take accountability
and i go but wait the biggest millennial
i know
is this 72 year old in the white house
but that doesn't
that didn't matter you know so that to
me yes
he almost he m you know emboldens that
uh to a degree or did
so certainly right so i i do think
that's part of it yeah it's a
combination of social media
it's the example that they've seen for
the last five years from the top of our
national experience everybody there's a
lot of factors that go into it there's a
lot of factors go into it
but at the core it's a generational
divide
and it's young kids trying to show off
either for their friends who
are in their immediate vicinity or
friends
strangers future followers whoever may
see it
on social media but social media is that
factor and it's just a combination of
human nature with these new technologies
so
i i i and at the end of the day the kid
apologized
so he he saw the light once he got hey
you know what it's easy to apologize
once you get the viral video out of it
yeah i'm sorry i'm sorry i did that
thing that
helped me have this video that millions
of people have now seen on tick tock and
elsewhere
sorry i did that thing even though maybe
deep down he's not sorry
lengthy apology there that was posted
and and fortunately
for you the audience the print is too
small for me to read the entire thing
i'll just say
there it is i would need a magnifying
glass to see it but you can find the
apology
online if you want to read the whole
thing again i don't know how sincere any
of it is because he got what he wanted
it's easy to apologize on the back end
especially after mom
and or dad find out about it insist on
the apology he's a kid you make mistakes
as a kid there's no doubt about that and
i'm sure yes
mom and dad and i think he says that his
parents didn't raise him to be that way
i got a little caught up in the moment
and that's okay it's forgivable
certainly and and he'll learn from that
well we got a little caught up in the
moment we had a lot more time talking
about that well i know i thought we were
going i'm sorry we jumped to it
but i saw cam and i just thought no it
was good you know it's all right
it's it's i'm just trying to transition
to the next topic look
we take whatever we can where we can and
have a nice meaty discussion even if it
wasn't something we expected to spend
that much time on i enjoyed it you
enjoyed it
whether or not the audience enjoyed it
is the real litmus test
hopefully they did and hopefully the 30
percent that turned the channel will
come back
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports